كنوز لا تقدر بثمن انه لارشيف الافغاني
مخطوطات قديمه ووثائق تاريخيه تعود العهود
شتى اما تحفه المخطوطات هنا فجزء من
القران الكريم كتب في القرن الاول الهجري
حسب القائمين على ارشيف افغانستان
حتى تقبل البكري ماتت الشيء المثير
للاهتمام هو ما كتبه سيدنا عثمان بن عفان
بيده على جلد الابل وبخط كوفي نقيم هذا
المعرض مرتين في السنه ليتمكن المواطنون
من زيارته وليتعرفوا على اثار بلدهم
في مبنى الارشيف والاثار ندوب الحروب
الاهليه لا تخطئها العين فالمبنى شيد قبل
نحو 130 سنه
واثناء الاشتباكات المسلحه تعرض للسرقه
والنهب عبد الرشيد عثمان عمل في الارشيف
الوطني ثلاثا وثلاثين سنه
نحاول جاهدين التواصل مع من لديهم مخطوطات
واثار قديمه ليقدموها هديه للارشيف الوطني
وعندما نخفق نقدم لهم عرضا ماليا لشراء ما
لديهم حتى لا يطمس تاريخ افغانستان
بعد الحروب الاهليه استعيد جزء من محتويات
الارشيف بطرق عده استعاده لارشيف الافغاني
ليست طرفا حتى في بلد مثل افغانستان
مزقته عقود من الحروب فهي ضروره يملها
واجب الحفاظ على ذاكره وهويه شعب باكمله
عمليات ترميم المخطوطات لا تتوقف فلا
ارشيف يحتوي على الاف الوثائق التاريخيه
هنا يتم جمعها وحفظها مع عدم اخفاء ترتيب
وثائق خرجت من القصر الرئاسي في عهود
سابقه
بينما يتم تصوير كل ما لديهم من وثائق
لارشفتها الكترونيا بهدف تعميم الفائده
على الباحثين والمهتمين بتاريخ افغانستان
ناصر شديد الجزيره كابول